Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Like many girls growing up in southern Italy in the early 60s, Seraphina Lococco was expected to marry young and start a family of her own. By age 15, Seraphina had chosen the man she wanted to be her future husband, a 20-year-old daughter leather cutter from her neighborhood named Pietro Santoro.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上的本期节目说明。像 60 年代初在意大利南部成长的许多女孩一样，塞拉菲娜·洛科科被期望早早结婚并组建自己的家庭。15 岁时，塞拉菲娜选择了她想成为未来丈夫的人，那是她邻居的一位 20 岁的皮革切割工，名叫彼得罗·桑托罗。
In contrast to socially progressive northern Italy, those on the island of Sicily still clung to the ancient belief that a girl's worth was measured by her chasteness. If she was a virgin before marriage, she was considered pure and worthy. If not, she was seen as shameful and immoral. No Sicilian man would marry what they judged a dishonoured woman. They feared her dishonour would jeopardise the family standing in the community and damage the marriage prospects of other female family members. Accordingly, Sicilian girls and young women were required to dress modestly and weren't
与社会进步的意大利北部相比，西西里岛的人们仍然固守着古老的观念，即女孩的价值由她的贞洁来衡量。如果她在婚前是处女，她就被认为是纯洁且值得尊重的。如果不是，她就会被视为可耻和不道德的。没有西西里男人会娶一个他们认为名誉扫地的女人。他们担心她的不名誉会危及家庭在社区中的地位，并损害家中其他女性成员的婚姻前景。因此，西西里女孩和年轻女性被要求穿着朴素，并且不被
permitted to socially interact with unmarried men. Court ships between young couples were strictly controlled by their families, and in Seraphina Lococco's case, her father did not like Pietro Santoro. Without his approval, there would be no marriage. One day in the summer of 1962, Pietro and Seraphina performed what was known as a fuetina, an elopement of sorts. They spent a week together hidden in the countryside, and upon her return home, Seraphina informed her father that she was now a dishonoured woman.
允许与未婚男子进行社交互动。年轻情侣之间的求爱受到家庭的严格控制，而在塞拉菲娜·洛科科的案例中，她的父亲不喜欢彼得罗·桑托罗。没有他的批准，就不会有婚姻。1962 年夏天的一天，彼得罗和塞拉菲娜上演了所谓的“私奔”（fuetina）。他们在乡村躲藏了一周，回到家后，塞拉菲娜告诉父亲，她现在是一个名誉扫地的女人了。
Her father understood the situation before him. His own honour, that of his family name, and of both his daughters, was at stake. Despite his ill feelings toward Pietro, Seraphina's father felt he had no choice. According to Sicilian culture dating back millennia, the dishonour could be entirely undone, repaired and restored by the matrimonio reparatore, the marriage between the girl and her lover. About 12 months later, another Sicilian man, 23-year-old Filippo Melodia, set his eyes on the most beautiful girl he had ever seen.
她的父亲明白眼前的处境。他自己的名誉、家族的名声以及两个女儿的名声都岌岌可危。尽管他对彼得罗心存不满，但塞拉菲娜的父亲觉得他别无选择。根据延续了数千年的西西里文化，这种不名誉可以通过“补救婚姻”（matrimonio reparatore），即女孩与她的情人结婚，来完全抵消、修复和恢复。大约 12 个月后，另一位西西里男子，23 岁的菲利波·梅洛迪亚，看中了他所见过的最美丽的女孩。
In the northwestern Sicilian town of Alcamo, many locals believed that Franca Viola's beauty was destined to lift her family out of poverty. Despite all the fanfare regarding her looks, Franca was an unassuming 15-year-old. She aspired to complete her education, live a comfortable life and travel the world. She also dreamed of falling in love. Unlike Franca Viola, whose family were poor farmers, Filippo Melodia was born into wealth. He was the nephew of the undisputed boss of the Casa Nostra, the Sicilian mafia. Filippo enjoyed all of the privileges that such an association offered.
在西西里西北部的小镇阿尔卡莫，许多当地人认为弗兰卡·维奥拉的美貌注定能让她的家庭摆脱贫困。尽管外界对她的美貌大肆渲染，但弗兰卡只是一个谦逊的 15 岁女孩。她渴望完成学业，过上舒适的生活，并环游世界。她也梦想着坠入爱河。与家庭贫困的农民弗兰卡·维奥拉不同，菲利波·梅洛迪亚出生于富裕家庭。他是西西里黑手党“卡萨诺斯特拉”（Cosa Nostra）无可争议的老大的侄子。菲利波享受着这种关系所带来的所有特权。
He drove around town in a white alpha Romeo Giulietta and spent his money freely, buying rounds of drinks for his friends at the bar almost daily. Given Alcamo was a stronghold for the Sicilian mafia, Filippo's position as a future leader was assured. With his money, good looks and status, Filippo was one of the town's most eligible bachelors. Yet, he only had eyes for Franca Viola. The pair had made an impact on each other as they exchanged glances and greetings around town.
他开着一辆白色的阿尔法·罗密欧朱丽叶在镇上兜风，花钱大手大脚，几乎每天都在酒吧为朋友们买单。鉴于阿尔卡莫是西西里黑手党的据点，菲利波作为未来领导者的地位是稳固的。凭借他的金钱、英俊的外表和地位，菲利波是镇上最抢手的单身汉之一。然而，他眼里只有弗兰卡·维奥拉。两人在镇上交换眼神和问候时，就已经对彼此产生了影响。
Franca had formed the belief that there was a decent husband hidden behind Filippo's flashy exterior and told her parents that she would be open to a courtship with him. Franca's father, Bernardo, was well aware of Filippo Melodia. He'd heard the many stories of Filippo terrorizing the neighborhoods of Alcamo, speeding through the narrow streets in his Giulietta and flashing around his 9mm pistol. Bernardo was also aware that the local police had their eye on Filippo. As a hard-working, honest and humble man, Bernardo Viola had little respect for the young mafia also.
弗兰卡形成了一种信念，认为菲利波浮华的外表下隐藏着一个正派的丈夫，并告诉父母她愿意与他交往。弗兰卡的父亲贝尔纳多非常了解菲利波·梅洛迪亚。他听过许多关于菲利波在阿尔卡莫街区横行霸道、开着他的朱丽叶在狭窄街道上飞驰并炫耀他那把 9 毫米手枪的故事。贝尔纳多也知道当地警察一直在盯着菲利波。作为一个勤劳、诚实且谦逊的人，贝尔纳多·维奥拉对这位年轻的黑手党成员没什么好感。
Years after Franca told her father about her growing feelings for Filippo, he arrived at the Viola house to introduce himself to her family and begin the courtship process. Once inside, Filippo announced his intention to be engaged to Franca. Bernardo was not easily intimidated. He wanted his daughter to marry a man who would take good care of her. Filippo retorted that there was no better man in Alcamo. Bernardo then implied that he would prefer Franca marry a man who worked for a living. Filippo was insulted by the remark, but remained quiet.
在弗兰卡告诉父亲她对菲利波的感情日益增长几年后，菲利波来到维奥拉家向她的家人介绍自己，并开始求爱过程。进入屋内后，菲利波宣布了他想与弗兰卡订婚的意图。贝尔纳多并不容易被吓倒。他希望女儿嫁给一个能好好照顾她的男人。菲利波反驳说，阿尔卡莫没有比他更好的男人了。贝尔纳多随后暗示，他更希望弗兰卡嫁给一个靠工作谋生的人。菲利波对这番话感到被冒犯，但保持了沉默。
Eventually, Bernardo broke the silence. Franca herself had expressed an interest in Filippo, so Bernardo was willing to consider an engagement between them on one condition. They got to know each other first. Filippo was not the type to take orders from someone he considered a peasant, and he wouldn't have tolerated such disrespect for any other girl. But he wanted Franca Viola as his wife, so he was willing to do as her father asked. The following week, Filippo and Franca sat side by side on a sofa inside the Viola house
最终，贝尔纳多打破了沉默。弗兰卡本人对菲利波表示了兴趣，所以贝尔纳多愿意考虑他们之间的订婚，但有一个条件：他们先要互相了解。菲利波不是那种会听从他认为的农民命令的人，他也不会容忍对其他女孩有这种不尊重。但他想让弗兰卡·维奥拉做他的妻子，所以他愿意按照她父亲的要求去做。接下来的一周，菲利波和弗兰卡并排坐在维奥拉家客厅的沙发上，
under the watchful eye of Franca's mother, Vita. Franca was initially charmed by Filippo, who confessed to Franca that he was crazy about her. However, after a number of months, Franca realized that she didn't harbor any romantic feelings for Filippo. She boasted constantly of his family's wealth, his car, and his connections to the mafia. He was also being looked into for a string of motorcycle thefts. Filippo had scoffed at Franca's plans for the future, insisting that she should be
在弗兰卡母亲维塔的注视下。弗兰卡最初被菲利波迷住了，菲利波向弗兰卡坦白他为她疯狂。然而，几个月后，弗兰卡意识到她对菲利波没有任何浪漫的感觉。他不断吹嘘他家族的财富、他的车以及他与黑手党的关系。他还在因一系列摩托车盗窃案而受到调查。菲利波对弗兰卡的未来计划嗤之以鼻，坚持认为她应该
satisfied simply by becoming his wife. Franca had glimpsed what her life with Filippo melodia would be like, and she was not impressed. The next time Filippo called at the Viola house, Franca didn't appear. Instead, her father informed the young man that he had failed his test. Without Bernardo's approval, Franca and Filippo's marriage would not go ahead. For the whole of 1964, the Viola family did not hear a word from Filippo melodia. After having been rejected by Franca and her father, Filippo had left Sicily and spent the year in Germany to save face.
仅仅通过成为他的妻子而感到满足。弗兰卡已经瞥见了她与菲利波·梅洛迪亚的生活会是什么样子，她并不感到印象深刻。下一次菲利波造访维奥拉家时，弗兰卡没有出现。相反，她的父亲告诉这个年轻人，他没能通过考验。没有贝尔纳多的批准，弗兰卡和菲利波的婚姻就不会进行。整个 1964 年，维奥拉一家没有收到菲利波·梅洛迪亚的任何消息。在被弗兰卡和她父亲拒绝后，菲利波离开了西西里，在德国度过了一年以挽回面子。
By early 1965, the atmosphere in Alcamo had changed. Many high-ranking Martbioso, including Filippo's uncle, had been arrested. The Costa Nostra no longer had the same stranglehold over the town. Those who remained free kept a low profile, wary of Alcamo's new police commissioner, Lorenzo Camilleri. Upon his return to Alcamo, Filippo was keen to pick up where he left off. He wanted what he thought was owed to him, the Martbioso lifestyle, and Franca Viola. His desire for her had only intensified during his absence.
到 1965 年初，阿尔卡莫的气氛发生了变化。包括菲利波的叔叔在内的许多高级黑手党成员被捕。卡萨诺斯特拉不再对该镇拥有同样的控制权。那些仍然自由的人保持低调，警惕着阿尔卡莫的新任警察局长洛伦佐·卡米莱里。回到阿尔卡莫后，菲利波渴望从他离开的地方重新开始。他想要他认为属于他的东西：黑手党的生活方式和弗兰卡·维奥拉。他对她的渴望在他离开期间只增不减。
In early May 1965, Filippo spied Bernardo Viola in town and approached him. In a callback to their first conversation, Filippo told Bernardo that he had been working while living in Germany, hoping to impress the older man. Bernardo replied, It was not a thing before, and it is not a thing now. Franca has not missed you, and she can find a better husband than you. A few weeks later, on Friday, May 28, Bernardo arrived at his farm, only to find the warehouse where he kept his farming tools on fire. Upon discovering several empty petrol cans around the building, Bernardo headed into
1965 年 5 月初，菲利波在镇上发现了贝尔纳多·维奥拉并接近了他。在回顾他们第一次谈话时，菲利波告诉贝尔纳多，他在德国生活期间一直在工作，希望能给这位长辈留下深刻印象。贝尔纳多回答说：“以前不是一回事，现在也不是。弗兰卡没有想念你，她能找到比你更好的丈夫。”几周后，5 月 28 日星期五，贝尔纳多回到他的农场，却发现存放农具的仓库着火了。在发现建筑物周围有几个空的汽油罐后，贝尔纳多前往
town to report the arson to the police. On the way, he crossed paths with Filippo Melodia. The young man smiled, as if in triumph. Later that evening, Bernardo was given the message, the fire was just a warning. Two months later, 500 vines were prematurely cut and destroyed on the Viola farm. This was a devastating financial blow to the family, whose entire income was derived from their harvest. They would just have to make do with the remaining crops.
镇上向警方报告纵火案。在路上，他与菲利波·梅洛迪亚擦肩而过。那个年轻人微笑着，仿佛在庆祝胜利。那天晚上晚些时候，贝尔纳多收到了消息：火灾只是一个警告。两个月后，维奥拉农场 500 株葡萄藤被提前砍伐并毁坏。这对家庭来说是一个毁灭性的经济打击，他们的全部收入都来自收成。他们只能凑合着剩下的作物过日子。
However, by October, these two had been destroyed. Bernardo had arrived to find sheep and cattle grazing in his field. There was nothing left. The destruction of his warehouse, tools and crops meant that the Viola family would not have any money for the coming year. When winter arrived, they would be forced to turn to public charity for food to eat. Bernardo maintained a cheerful public facade, but privately, he was humiliated. The following day, Filippo Melodia and two of his friends arrived at Bernardo's farm.
然而，到了 10 月，这两样东西也被毁了。贝尔纳多赶到时发现羊和牛在他的田里吃草。什么都没剩下。仓库、工具和作物的毁坏意味着维奥拉一家在接下来的一年里将没有任何钱。冬天到来时，他们将被迫求助于公共慈善机构来获取食物。贝尔纳多在公共场合保持着开朗的面孔，但私下里，他感到羞辱。第二天，菲利波·梅洛迪亚和他的两个朋友来到了贝尔纳多的农场。
Filippo informed Bernardo that he must forfeit his farming land within three days. He then lifted his shirt to reveal a 9mm pistol tucked into his waistband. There was no question that Filippo was responsible for the damage to the Viola farm, but without any proof, there was nothing the police could do. Meanwhile, Franca Viola had become so terrified of Filippo that she barely left her home in fear of what he'd do next. On Christmas Day, Filippo Melodia gathered his crew. Let Franca enjoy mass with her family, he told his boys.
菲利波通知贝尔纳多，他必须在三天内放弃他的农田。然后他掀起衬衫，露出别在腰带里的一把 9 毫米手枪。毫无疑问，菲利波应对维奥拉农场的损失负责，但由于没有任何证据，警察无能为力。与此同时，弗兰卡·维奥拉对菲利波感到非常恐惧，以至于她几乎不敢离开家，害怕他接下来会做什么。圣诞节那天，菲利波·梅洛迪亚召集了他的手下。“让弗兰卡和她的家人享受弥撒吧，”他告诉他的小伙子们。
Tomorrow, they would ride. At 7am on Sunday, December 26, 1965, two men on a scooter slowly rode down the narrow streets of central Alcamo. They turned into Via Ro Rancho, passing the near-identical sandstone-coloured buildings that lined the street until they reached number 41. They idled in place for a moment before moving a little further away to an acceptable vantage point. Eventually, they saw a short, slightly-paunched man in a flat cap and jacket leave the building.
明天，他们就会行动。1965 年 12 月 26 日星期日早上 7 点，两名骑着踏板车的男子缓慢地穿过阿尔卡莫市中心的狭窄街道。他们转入兰乔街（Via Ro Rancho），经过街道两旁几乎一模一样的砂岩色建筑，直到到达 41 号。他们在原地闲逛了一会儿，然后移动到稍远一点的可接受的有利位置。最终，他们看到一个戴着平顶帽和夹克、略显臃肿的男人离开了大楼。
Once he was out of sight, the scooter's engine buzzed and the two men hurriedly disappeared. About 30 minutes later, a blue Fiat Secento and a white Alfa Romeo Giulietta screeched to a halt outside number 41. Several gunshots were fired into the air as a warning to residents to stay inside and mind their business. Twelve masked and armed men then piled out of the cars and forced their way inside the Viola home. Vita Viola screamed for her daughter to run, knowing the men had come to take Franca away.
当他消失在视线中后，踏板车的引擎嗡嗡作响，两人匆忙消失了。大约 30 分钟后，一辆蓝色菲亚特 600 和一辆白色阿尔法·罗密欧朱丽叶在 41 号门外急刹车停下。几声枪响向空中射出，作为警告，让居民待在室内，不要多管闲事。随后，12 名蒙面武装人员从车里涌出，强行闯入维奥拉家中。维塔·维奥拉尖叫着让女儿快跑，因为她知道这些人是来带走弗兰卡的。
Vita tried to fight them off, but they knocked her down and kept her pinned to the ground. Franca rushed upstairs, only to be chased down by four men who dragged her back down and out the front door. Franca's eight-year-old brother Mariano clung to her legs, refusing to let go even when he was struck over and over. Franca and Mariano were thrown into the Alfa Romeo Giulietta. After the car doors slammed shut, the two men who were still inside the house released their grip on Vita, who immediately ran outside after her children.
维塔试图反抗，但他们把她打倒在地，并按住她。弗兰卡冲上楼，却被四名男子追上，他们把她拖回楼下并拖出前门。弗兰卡 8 岁的弟弟马里亚诺紧紧抓住她的腿，即使被反复殴打也不肯松手。弗兰卡和马里亚诺被扔进了阿尔法·罗密欧朱丽叶车里。车门砰地关上后，留在屋里的两名男子松开了对维塔的控制，维塔立即跑出屋外追赶她的孩子们。
Before she could reach the car, she was punched in the head from behind and fell to the ground. A dozen more gunshots were fired into the air before the Giulietta and Secento sped away. Bernardo Viola returned home as quickly as he could and reported the kidnapping of Franca and Mariano to Commissioner Lorenzo Camilleri. Vita Viola knew for certain who had kidnapped her children. Although he'd been wearing a mask, Vita had locked eyes with Filippo Melodia as he dragged Franca away. Despite knowing who was responsible, Bernardo and Vita were at a loss.
在她到达车前之前，她从背后被击中头部，倒在地上。在朱丽叶和菲亚特疾驰而去之前，又有十几声枪响射向空中。贝尔纳多·维奥拉尽快赶回家，向洛伦佐·卡米莱里局长报告了弗兰卡和马里亚诺被绑架的消息。维塔·维奥拉确切地知道是谁绑架了她的孩子。尽管他戴着面具，但维塔在菲利波·梅洛迪亚拖走弗兰卡时与他四目相对。尽管知道是谁干的，贝尔纳多和维塔还是束手无策。
In the memory of Filippo's mafia connections, the couple's neighbours refused to offer assistance or information. Fortunately for the Violas, Commissioner Lorenzo Camilleri wasn't one to just sit around and wait. He immediately began searching for Franca. Filippo Melodia sped away from Alcamo and into the countryside. With him, Franca and Mariano Viola clung tightly to one another in the back seat. Filippo told Franca that after he was done with her, she would not be able to marry any
由于菲利波的黑手党关系，这对夫妇的邻居拒绝提供帮助或信息。幸运的是，对于维奥拉一家来说，洛伦佐·卡米莱里局长不是那种只会坐着等待的人。他立即开始寻找弗兰卡。菲利波·梅洛迪亚从阿尔卡莫疾驰而去，进入乡村。和他在一起的弗兰卡和马里亚诺·维奥拉在后座紧紧抱在一起。菲利波告诉弗兰卡，在他对她做完那些事后，她将无法嫁给除他之外的任何
other man but him. In defiance, she shouted that she did not love him. Filippo laughed and retorted, who cares? The Giulietta eventually came to a stop in front of a remote farmhouse. Eight-year-old Mariano was pried away from his sister and driven back towards Alcamo. He was later found abandoned on the outskirts of town. Meanwhile, Franca was dragged inside the farmhouse screaming, but there was nobody around to hear her cries for help.
男人。出于反抗，她大喊她不爱他。菲利波大笑并反驳道：“谁在乎呢？”朱丽叶最终停在了一座偏僻的农舍前。8 岁的马里亚诺被从他姐姐身边强行拉开，开车送回了阿尔卡莫方向。他后来被发现被遗弃在镇郊。与此同时，弗兰卡被尖叫着拖进农舍，但周围没有人听到她的求救声。
For six days, she was starved, taunted and insulted by Filippo Melodia. By the seventh day, Franca was weak. She lay on the floor, semi-conscious and barely able to move. Filippo then raped her for the first time. He knew under any circumstances where an unmarried girl or young woman loses her virginity, even in the case of rape, she would become a shamed woman. The dishonour to herself and her family could then only be repaired through the matrimonio reparatore.
六天来，她一直被菲利波·梅洛迪亚挨饿、嘲弄和侮辱。到了第七天，弗兰卡变得虚弱。她躺在地板上，半昏迷，几乎无法动弹。菲利波随后第一次强奸了她。他知道在任何情况下，未婚女孩或年轻女性失去贞操，即使是在强奸的情况下，她也会成为一个蒙羞的女人。她自己和家人的不名誉随后只能通过“补救婚姻”来修复。
To enact such a fuitina as the one Filippo was doing was most certainly a crime, but Filippo knew the law was on his side. Article 544 of the Criminal Code read, quote, The crimes of kidnap and rape would be extinguished by the marriage between the victim and her rapist. This law applied even if the victim was a minor. At the beginning of January, Filippo covertly relocated Franca from the farmhouse to his sister's house in Alcamo. By this stage, the Melodia family had been in contact with the Viola family and negotiations
实施菲利波所做的这种“私奔”当然是一种犯罪，但菲利波知道法律站在他这一边。刑法第 544 条写道：“绑架和强奸罪将因受害者与强奸者结婚而消灭。”即使受害者是未成年人，该法律也适用。1 月初，菲利波秘密将弗兰卡从农舍转移到他姐姐在阿尔卡莫的家中。到这个阶段，梅洛迪亚家族已经与维奥拉家族取得了联系，谈判
were underway. Knowing full well what Filippo was up to with Franca, the two families were nearing an agreement on a wedding date. On Thursday, January 6, 1966, 12 days after Franca Viola was kidnapped, Commissioner Lorenzo Camilleri and his officers had Filippo Melodia's sister's house surrounded. They demanded that Filippo release Franca immediately. There was a commotion from inside the house and then suddenly, two figures appeared on the second story balcony.
正在进行中。完全清楚菲利波对弗兰卡做了什么，两个家庭即将就婚礼日期达成协议。1966 年 1 月 6 日星期四，弗兰卡·维奥拉被绑架 12 天后，洛伦佐·卡米莱里局长和他的警官包围了菲利波·梅洛迪亚姐姐的房子。他们要求菲利波立即释放弗兰卡。屋内传来一阵骚动，突然，二楼阳台上出现了两个身影。
Filippo held up a visibly weak Franca Viola in front of him. As the officers leveled their guns at Filippo, Franca shouted, Don't shoot. The police lowered their weapons. Satisfied with this outcome, Filippo agreed to surrender Franca and watched as his teenage captive collapsed into the waiting arms of her father. Filippo offered no resistance when Commissioner Camilleri placed him under arrest. He just smiled broadly and asked for a cigarette. Filippo then looked to Franca in anticipation.
菲利波把虚弱的弗兰卡·维奥拉挡在身前。当警官们把枪对准菲利波时，弗兰卡大喊：“别开枪。”警察放下了武器。对这个结果感到满意，菲利波同意交出弗兰卡，并看着他那十几岁的俘虏倒在她父亲等待的怀抱中。当卡米莱里局长将他逮捕时，菲利波没有反抗。他只是咧嘴一笑，要了一支烟。菲利波随后期待地看向弗兰卡。
He believed she would insist that he be released and become her husband, as it was the only way she could remedy the disgrace she now brought upon her family as a dishonoured woman. Franca paused in front of Filippo Melodia, looked him in the eyes, and told him, I will never marry you, goodbye. Filippo's smile vanished and the police took him away. Reunited with her family and safely back home, Franca agonized over rumours that her father had agreed for her to be married to Filippo during her time in captivity. Leonardo assured his daughter that the marriage negotiations were just a ruse in order for
他相信她会坚持要求释放他并成为她的丈夫，因为这是她作为一名名誉扫地的女人，补救她现在给家人带来的耻辱的唯一途径。弗兰卡在菲利波·梅洛迪亚面前停下，直视他的眼睛，告诉他：“我永远不会嫁给你，再见。”菲利波的笑容消失了，警察把他带走了。与家人团聚并安全回到家后，弗兰卡为关于她父亲在被囚禁期间同意她嫁给菲利波的传言而感到痛苦。莱昂纳多向女儿保证，婚姻谈判只是为了让
Commissioner Camilleri to discover where she was being held. With no marriage planned, Franca's fate and that of her family was uncertain. Vita worried for her daughter's future, but Franca was confident in her decision. She insisted that she would rather remain unmarried her entire life than be married to a man such as Filippo Melodia, a man without honour. In standing her ground, Franca Viola had become the first Sicilian to ever refuse a matrimonio reparatore with her rapist. Bernardo Viola just wanted his daughter to be safe and happy, but he knew that the price
卡米莱里局长发现她被关押在哪里而设的计谋。由于没有婚姻计划，弗兰卡和她家人的命运是不确定的。维塔为女儿的未来感到担忧，但弗兰卡对自己的决定充满信心。她坚持认为，她宁愿终身不嫁，也不愿嫁给像菲利波·梅洛迪亚这样没有名誉的男人。通过坚持自己的立场，弗兰卡·维奥拉成为了第一个拒绝与强奸者进行“补救婚姻”的西西里人。贝尔纳多·维奥拉只是希望他的女儿安全快乐，但他知道
for her resolve would be high. Within the months leading up to Filippo Melodia's trial, life for the Viola family was grim. The earlier destruction of their farm meant that they had little money and food was scarce. Bernardo was desperate to find work, but no one in the town or surrounding villages would hire him. Franca became reclusive, shutting herself inside her home to avoid hostilities and judgement from the public. The Violas were guarded around the clock by police to ensure none of Filippo Melodia's
她决心的代价将是高昂的。在菲利波·梅洛迪亚审判前的几个月里，维奥拉一家的生活很凄惨。他们农场早先的毁坏意味着他们几乎没有钱，食物也很匮乏。贝尔纳多拼命想找工作，但镇上或周边村庄没有人愿意雇佣他。弗兰卡变得孤僻，把自己关在家里，以避免公众的敌意和评判。维奥拉一家由警察全天候守卫，以确保菲利波·梅洛迪亚的
family or friends followed through on their death threats. Many of the townspeople admired Franca's courage, but they still considered her decision to be ill-advised. They believed that even a girl as pretty as Franca would never find a husband now. Not only was she dishonoured, but she was also poor. During a council meeting for the town of Alcamo, it was proposed that the council stand in solidarity with Franca, her family, and all others who had been bullied. The proposition was unanimously approved, but when one councillor stood up and rhetorically
家人或朋友不会实施他们的死亡威胁。许多镇民钦佩弗兰卡的勇气，但他们仍然认为她的决定是不明智的。他们认为，即使像弗兰卡这样漂亮的女孩，现在也永远找不到丈夫了。她不仅名誉扫地，而且还很穷。在阿尔卡莫镇的一次议会会议上，有人提议议会与弗兰卡、她的家人以及所有其他被欺负的人站在一起。该提议获得了一致通过，但当一名议员站起来并反问式地
requested a show of hands as to who among them would be willing to marry any dishonoured woman. No one moved. In December 1966, Franca Viola and her parents arrived at the Trappany Courthouse under armed police escort. Of the 500 or so spectators who packed the courtroom, the vast majority were the family and supporters of Filippo Melodia and his accomplices. The room was powerfully hostile towards the Viola family, who endured the crowd's insults
要求举手表决谁愿意娶任何名誉扫地的女人时，没有人动。1966 年 12 月，弗兰卡·维奥拉和她的父母在武装警察的护送下抵达特拉帕尼法院。在挤满法庭的 500 名左右的旁观者中，绝大多数是菲利波·梅洛迪亚及其同伙的家人和支持者。法庭对维奥拉一家非常敌视，他们忍受着人群的侮辱
and death threats. Even their lawyer was met with the jeez and spit. The Violas sat behind the public prosecutor and their own lawyer. On the other side of the room were the lawyers representing each of the accused. All 12 of the defendants, including Filippo Melodia, were present inside the courtroom, locked behind the defendants' bars. Under oath, Filippo Melodia told the court that he and Franca Viola were in love and that her father, Bernardo, had called off their engagement against Franca's wishes.
和死亡威胁。甚至他们的律师也遭到了嘲笑和唾骂。维奥拉一家坐在公诉人和他们自己的律师身后。房间的另一边是代表每位被告的律师。包括菲利波·梅洛迪亚在内的所有 12 名被告都出现在法庭内，被锁在被告席里。在宣誓后，菲利波·梅洛迪亚告诉法庭，他和弗兰卡·维奥拉相爱，她的父亲贝尔纳多违背弗兰卡的意愿取消了他们的订婚。
Filippo said that he and Franca had arranged the Fuitina together in order to force her father's hand. He claimed that they had been consensually intimate many times during their escape, but it was old news, as they had already had sex two years prior during their initial courtship. He elaborated, saying that there were moments during his visits to the Viola house where he and Franca were unsupervised. To prove their client's assertions, Filippo's defense team requested that their medical
菲利波说，他和弗兰卡一起安排了“私奔”，以迫使她父亲就范。他声称他们在逃跑期间多次自愿亲密接触，但这已经是旧闻了，因为他们在最初求爱期间就已经发生过性关系。他详细说明，说在他访问维奥拉家期间，他和弗兰卡有无人看管的时刻。为了证明他们当事人的主张，菲利波的辩护团队要求他们的医疗
expert be granted permission to physically examine Franca Viola in order to prove that she lost her virginity many months or even years prior to the Fuitina. The prosecution vigorously objected to the request, and it was ultimately denied by the court. Filippo also claimed that he and Franca had planned the details of the staged kidnapping the day prior on Christmas Day. In a show of solidarity with his co-accused, Filippo stated that while he had received assistance, none of the other eleven men charged had been present at the time of the phony
专家获准对弗兰卡·维奥拉进行身体检查，以证明她在“私奔”前许多个月甚至几年就已经失去了贞操。检方强烈反对这一请求，并最终被法庭驳回。菲利波还声称，他和弗兰卡在前一天，即圣诞节那天，计划了这场虚假绑架的细节。为了表示与共同被告的团结，菲利波表示，虽然他得到了帮助，但其他 11 名被指控的男子中没有一人在虚假
kidnapping. He declined to name any of his actual helpers. Given the Fuitina was an agreed upon arrangement between himself and Franca, no actual kidnap or rape had been committed. Filippo Melodia concluded that Franca's true wish was to marry him, but her tyrannical father would not allow it. After Filippo stepped down, the defense called a long procession of witnesses who supported his claims.
绑架时在场。他拒绝透露他任何实际帮手的名字。鉴于“私奔”是他和弗兰卡之间商定的安排，没有发生实际的绑架或强奸。菲利波·梅洛迪亚总结说，弗兰卡的真实愿望是嫁给他，但她专横的父亲不允许。在菲利波下台后，辩方传唤了一长串支持他主张的证人。
One by one they provided alibis for each of Filippo's accomplices. Most were said to have been at work all day, some at home, one in the market in town and one at the barbers. In support of Filippo's claims that he and Franca were in love and the Fuitina had been pre-planned between them, the defense called a woman named Anna Longaro. Anna lived next door to Filippo's sister and witnessed the brief standoff between Filippo and the police. Anna testified that Franca had not shouted, don't shoot in fear of her own safety, but
他们一个接一个地为菲利波的每一位同伙提供了不在场证明。大多数人被说成整天都在工作，一些人在家，一个在镇上的市场，一个在理发店。为了支持菲利波关于他和弗兰卡相爱且“私奔”是预先计划好的主张，辩方传唤了一位名叫安娜·隆加罗的妇女。安娜住在菲利波姐姐隔壁，目睹了菲利波和警察之间短暂的对峙。安娜作证说，弗兰卡并没有因为担心自己的安全而大喊“别开枪”，而是
had actually yelled, don't shoot, he is my husband, in order to protect the man she loved from the officer's bullets. As the defense concluded their case, none of the twelve accused men in the defendant's cage seemed at all worried about their fate. They talked and joked amongst themselves, smoked cigarettes and laughed. The prosecution's argument was simple. In clear violation of the law, the twelve defendants had kidnapped Franca Viola and then Filippo Melodia had raped her multiple times.
实际上大喊“别开枪，他是我的丈夫”，以保护她所爱的男人免受警察子弹的伤害。随着辩方结束陈述，被告席上的 12 名被告似乎一点也不担心他们的命运。他们互相交谈、开玩笑、抽烟并大笑。检方的论点很简单。在明显违反法律的情况下，12 名被告绑架了弗兰卡·维奥拉，然后菲利波·梅洛迪亚多次强奸了她。
The prosecution conceded that under section 544 of the criminal code, these actions would cease to be crimes in relation to all defendants, if and when Franca Viola married Filippo Melodia. However, given Franca's continued refusal to do so, which was her right, the fact of the crimes remained. Whether in fear of physical reprisal or simply the social stigma, no one in the community was willing to testify on behalf of the Viola family. The prosecution's case was limited to what those within the family claimed on the stand. Both Vita and Bernardo testified as to the events leading up to their daughter's abduction.
检方承认，根据刑法第 544 条，如果弗兰卡·维奥拉嫁给菲利波·梅洛迪亚，这些行为将不再构成针对所有被告的犯罪。然而，鉴于弗兰卡持续拒绝这样做（这是她的权利），犯罪的事实依然存在。无论是出于对身体报复的恐惧，还是仅仅因为社会耻辱，社区中没有人愿意代表维奥拉一家作证。检方的案件仅限于家庭成员在证人席上所声称的内容。维塔和贝尔纳多都就导致他们女儿被绑架的事件作了证。
They confirmed that back in 1963, Franca was indeed engaged to Filippo Melodia, albeit conditionally on the two becoming more acquainted. After spending time with Filippo, Franca had realized that she did not want to marry him and so his proposal was rejected. Franca's parents testified to the campaign of intimidation and destruction that followed. Despite the defense's attempts to prove otherwise, Vita maintained that all of Filippo's accomplices were in the courtroom that day. Even though they had been wearing face coverings when they took her daughter, Vita was able
他们证实，早在 1963 年，弗兰卡确实与菲利波·梅洛迪亚订婚了，尽管是以两人更加了解为条件的。在与菲利波相处一段时间后，弗兰卡意识到她不想嫁给他，所以他的求婚被拒绝了。弗兰卡的父母作证了随后的恐吓和破坏活动。尽管辩方试图证明事实并非如此，但维塔坚持认为菲利波的所有同伙那天都在法庭上。尽管他们在带走她女儿时戴着面罩，但维塔还是能够
to recognize all of those involved. Franca's aunt and grandmother both testified that they, along with Franca's parents and her brother Mariano, all enjoyed Christmas Day together. No time did Franca have any interaction or conversation with Filippo as he had claimed. Finally, Franca Viola sat in the witness box. She described her ordeal at the hands of Filippo Melodia in clear and precise detail. She denied that the Fuitina had been pre-planned between them, maintaining that none of what she had endured was consensual.
认出所有参与者。弗兰卡的姑姑和祖母都作证说，她们和弗兰卡的父母以及她的弟弟马里亚诺一起享受了圣诞节。弗兰卡从未像他所声称的那样与菲利波有任何互动或交谈。最后，弗兰卡·维奥拉坐在证人席上。她清晰而精确地描述了她在菲利波·梅洛迪亚手中的遭遇。她否认“私奔”是他们预先计划好的，坚持认为她所忍受的一切都不是自愿的。
Franca firmly stated that she was not now or had ever been in love with Filippo Melodia. Franca was pressed as to why she had now gone against all tradition by refusing to marry Filippo and restore her own honor and the social standing of her family. She replied, I am not the property of anyone. Honor is lost by those who do certain things, not those who suffer them. After providing her testimony, Franca stayed away from the courthouse for the remainder of the trial.
弗兰卡坚定地表示，她现在没有，也从来没有爱过菲利波·梅洛迪亚。弗兰卡被追问为什么她现在违背了所有传统，拒绝嫁给菲利波以恢复她自己的名誉和她家庭的社会地位。她回答说：“我不是任何人的财产。名誉是由那些做某些事情的人失去的，而不是那些遭受这些事情的人。”在提供证词后，弗兰卡在审判的剩余时间里远离了法院。
She could no longer face the endless intrusion of reporters and photographers, nor the constant demand by Filippo Melodia's supporters to drop the charges and marry him. Instead, Franca would rely on her father's reports of the day's proceedings. Despite continued threats to his life, Bernardo never missed the day of the trial. In their closing statement, the prosecution requested exemplary sentences for each of the defendants to illustrate to everyone that violence should not be rewarded. They suggested that Filippo Melodia's accomplices received sentences ranging from four months to 13 years, proportionate to their respective roles in the kidnap of Franca Viola.
她再也无法面对记者和摄影师无休止的侵扰，也无法面对菲利波·梅洛迪亚的支持者不断要求撤销指控并嫁给他的要求。相反，弗兰卡依靠她父亲对当天诉讼程序的报告。尽管生命受到持续威胁，贝尔纳多从未错过审判的任何一天。在结案陈词中，检方要求对每名被告判处惩戒性刑罚，以向所有人说明暴力不应得到奖励。他们建议菲利波·梅洛迪亚的同伙根据他们在绑架弗兰卡·维奥拉中的各自角色，被判处 4 个月到 13 年不等的刑期。
Or Filippo himself, a sentence of 22 years and 10 months was put forward as deserving and just. The defense continued to argue that no crime had been committed, as Franca was in on the entire plot. But, should the court find cause for a conviction, the defense said it would be unfair for Filippo Melodia to pay dearly for his actions committed in accordance with the social customs of the time. On the seventh and final day of the trial, the presiding judges retired to deliberate
对于菲利波本人，建议判处 22 年 10 个月的刑期，这是应得且公正的。辩方继续辩称没有发生犯罪，因为弗兰卡参与了整个阴谋。但是，如果法庭发现有定罪的理由，辩方表示，让菲利波·梅洛迪亚为他按照当时社会习俗所采取的行动付出沉重代价是不公平的。在审判的第七天也是最后一天，主审法官退庭审议
the case. To the local community and Sicily as a whole, the trial marked a potential turning point in their social history. At 5.30 that evening, the judges delivered their verdict. The court found resoundingly in favour of Franca Viola and sentenced Filippo Melodia to 11 years in prison for kidnap and rape. Eight out of his 11 accomplices also received prison sentences. The reaction of those in the courtroom was stunned silence.
此案。对于当地社区和整个西西里岛来说，这次审判标志着他们社会历史的一个潜在转折点。那天晚上 5 点 30 分，法官宣读了判决。法庭响亮地支持弗兰卡·维奥拉，并以绑架和强奸罪判处菲利波·梅洛迪亚 11 年监禁。他的 11 名同伙中有 8 人也被判处监禁。法庭内的人们的反应是震惊的沉默。
Italian newspaper La Stampa reported, and with Filippo Melodia, this lesson will be listened to by many other Sicilians, who, like it or not, will have to know that something new is stirring in our countryside. As the courtroom emptied, reporters were able to briefly speak with the patriarch of the Melodia and Viola families. Filippo Melodia's father, Vincenzo, indicated he was not at all worried about his son's conviction, as there was still time for the matrimonio reparatore. With such a marriage, the law allowed his son's crimes to fall away even after the
意大利报纸《新闻报》（La Stampa）报道称：“随着菲利波·梅洛迪亚的判决，这一教训将被许多其他西西里人听到，无论他们喜欢与否，他们都必须知道，我们的乡村正在酝酿着新的东西。”随着法庭清空，记者们得以简短地与梅洛迪亚和维奥拉家族的族长交谈。菲利波·梅洛迪亚的父亲文森佐表示，他一点也不担心他儿子的定罪，因为还有时间进行“补救婚姻”。通过这样的婚姻，法律允许他儿子的罪行即使在
sentence had been handed down. Vincenzo was upbeat, suggesting that the wedding could be arranged very quickly. He stated, I really don't understand why Bernardo doesn't want to. In his place, I would have married Franco and Filippo. In contrast, Bernardo Viola remained steadfast that his daughter would never marry Filippo Melodia. The Viola family were simply keen to get on with their lives.
判决下达后也可以免除。文森佐很乐观，建议婚礼可以很快安排。他说：“我真的不明白为什么贝尔纳多不想。如果我是他，我会让弗兰卡和菲利波结婚。”相比之下，贝尔纳多·维奥拉坚定地认为他的女儿永远不会嫁给菲利波·梅洛迪亚。维奥拉一家只是渴望继续他们的生活。
When asked about Franco's future, Bernardo confirmed that she had obtained her driver's license and was studying to become a typist. During the previous year, Franco had received dozens of letters of support for her decision not to marry her rapist, and she had already received hundreds of written marriage proposals. Bernardo was confident that Franco would be just fine. Shortly after the trial, Filippo Melodia's legal team appealed his sentence, and in July 1967, they were marginally successful. Filippo's sentence was reduced to 10 years in prison with two years of supervised confinement.
当被问及弗兰卡的未来时，贝尔纳多证实她已经获得了驾照，并正在学习成为一名打字员。在过去的一年里，弗兰卡收到了数十封支持她不嫁给强奸者决定的信件，并且她已经收到了数百份书面求婚。贝尔纳多相信弗兰卡会没事的。审判后不久，菲利波·梅洛迪亚的法律团队对他的判决提出了上诉，并于 1967 年 7 月取得了微小的成功。菲利波的刑期被减为 10 年监禁，外加 2 年的监督监禁。
It was still dark on the morning of Wednesday, December 4, 1968, as 20-year-old Franco Viola walked slowly down the aisle between the chapel's pews. A bouquet of orange blossoms stood out against her white satin and lace dress, and her smile radiated through the white veil that covered her face. At the end of the aisle was 25-year-old accountant Giuseppe Roussi. Franco and Giuseppe had gone to school together and had lost touch in the years that followed. They were reacquainted at a reunion between their families in 1966, right before Franco was about to face Filippo Melodia in court.
1968 年 12 月 4 日星期三早上，天还没亮，20 岁的弗兰卡·维奥拉缓慢地走在教堂长椅之间的过道上。一束橙花在她的白色缎面和蕾丝礼服上格外显眼，她的笑容透过覆盖着她脸庞的白色面纱散发出来。过道的尽头是 25 岁的会计师朱塞佩·鲁西。弗兰卡和朱塞佩曾一起上学，在随后的几年里失去了联系。他们在 1966 年两家人的团聚中重新认识，就在弗兰卡即将要在法庭上面对菲利波·梅洛迪亚之前。
Franco was already dealing with the severe public scrutiny of that decision, so she had kept her courtship with the Giuseppe a secret. He became her rock, calling Franco regularly as she remained hidden away in her home waiting for updates on the trial from her father. After the stress and attention of that ordeal faded away, Giuseppe proposed. At first, Franco refused. She feared that Filippo Melodia would find out and have Giuseppe killed. However, Giuseppe persisted, telling Franco that he'd rather spend a short life as her
弗兰卡已经在处理那个决定带来的严厉公众审查，所以她对朱塞佩的求爱保密。他成了她的支柱，在弗兰卡躲在家里等待父亲审判更新时，经常给弗兰卡打电话。在那场磨难的压力和关注消退后，朱塞佩求婚了。起初，弗兰卡拒绝了。她担心菲利波·梅洛迪亚会发现并派人杀了朱塞佩。然而，朱塞佩坚持不懈，告诉弗兰卡，他宁愿作为她的丈夫度过短暂的一生，也不愿与任何其他女人共度一生。
husband than a whole life with any other woman. As soon as Franco accepted his proposal, Giuseppe applied for the marriage license and, as a contingency, a license to carry. Franco and Giuseppe opted to keep their wedding ceremony a small and private affair. Many close friends and family were invited, and the ceremony took place at dawn. A number of the police who had protected the violas in the lead-up to and during the trial were in attendance. As was Franco's lawyer, who had become a close friend of the family since the trial.
弗兰卡一接受他的求婚，朱塞佩就申请了结婚证，并作为应急措施，申请了持枪证。弗兰卡和朱塞佩选择将他们的婚礼仪式保持得小而私密。许多亲密的朋友和家人受邀，仪式在黎明时分举行。在审判前和审判期间保护维奥拉一家的许多警察也出席了。弗兰卡的律师也出席了，自审判以来，他已成为该家庭的密友。
Franco and Giuseppe received congratulations and wedding gifts from the Italian President Giuseppe Saragat and from the Italian Prime Minister Giovanni Leone. As the sun rose on their nuptials, the newlyweds made their way to Rome for a private audience with the Pope. After serving 10 years for the kidnapped rape of Franco Viola, Filippo Melodia was released from prison. He was immediately transported to Northern Italy, where he would be confined to the town of Mordena for the next two years to complete his sentence under supervised release.
弗兰卡和朱塞佩收到了意大利总统朱塞佩·萨拉加特和意大利总理乔瓦尼·莱昂内的祝贺和结婚礼物。随着太阳升起，这对新婚夫妇前往罗马与教皇进行私人会见。在因绑架和强奸弗兰卡·维奥拉服刑 10 年后，菲利波·梅洛迪亚被释放出狱。他立即被转移到意大利北部，在那里他将被限制在摩德纳镇两年，以在监督释放下完成他的刑期。
At no point did Filippo show any remorse for his crimes. On Wednesday, April 12, 1978, after finishing his day's work at an auto body shop, 38-year-old Filippo Melodia made his way to a bar near his apartment. Still wearing his dirty work overalls, he sat down to watch a replay of the day's Champions League football match on the bar's television screen. Just after 8.30pm, the owner of the bar called out to Filippo from across the room, telling him that he had a phone call. A police marshal was on the other line, Filippo was told.
菲利波从未对他的罪行表现出任何悔意。1978 年 4 月 12 日星期三，在汽车修理厂结束一天的工作后，38 岁的菲利波·梅洛迪亚前往他公寓附近的一家酒吧。仍然穿着脏兮兮的工作服，他坐下来观看酒吧电视屏幕上当天冠军联赛足球比赛的重播。晚上 8 点 30 分刚过，酒吧老板从房间对面叫住菲利波，告诉他有一个电话。菲利波被告知，电话那头是一位警官。
He strode over to the phone and announced his presence down the receiver, but there was no response. Untroubled, Filippo hung up the phone and decided to head home. As he went to leave, two men appeared and blocked his path. One of the men lifted a shotgun and fired twice into Filippo's chest. It was a textbook mafia execution. On Monday, December 19, 1966, less than 48 hours after Filippo Melodia was found guilty and sentenced to prison, 22-year-old Mateo Charavolo was walking with her mother down
他大步走到电话前，对着听筒宣布了他的身份，但没有回应。菲利波没有感到不安，挂断了电话，决定回家。当他准备离开时，两名男子出现并挡住了他的去路。其中一名男子举起一把猎枪，向菲利波的胸部开了两枪。这是一次教科书式的黑手党处决。1966 年 12 月 19 日星期一，在菲利波·梅洛迪亚被判有罪并入狱不到 48 小时后，22 岁的马特奥·查拉沃洛正和她的母亲走在
a street in the Sicilian town of Salami. All of a sudden, a car stopped alongside Mateo and three men wrangled her into the vehicle. Mateo's mother was knocked to the ground and could do nothing but watch as the men drove away with her daughter. Mateo was held captive and repeatedly raped by her ex-fiancé Andrea Viettiosso. After four days, the police tracked down Mateo to an empty cottage on the outskirts of town. Andrea Viettiosso insisted that no crime had been committed, as Mateo had agreed to marry him.
西西里萨拉米镇的一条街道上。突然，一辆车停在马特奥旁边，三名男子把她强行拉进车里。马特奥的母亲被撞倒在地，除了看着男人们带着她的女儿开车离开外，什么也做不了。马特奥被她的前未婚夫安德烈亚·维蒂奥索囚禁并反复强奸。四天后，警察在镇郊的一间空小屋里找到了马特奥。安德烈亚·维蒂奥索坚持认为没有发生犯罪，因为马特奥已经同意嫁给他。
With the support of her family and emboldened by the courage and resolve of Franca Viola before her, Mateo denounced her rapist. She told the police that she had never agreed to run away with Andrea and that she would never marry him. Mateo had Andrea Viettiosso charged immediately. Twenty-four days later, 18-year-old Carmela Parisi was kidnapped in central Sicily and raped by Franco Mattura. Despite her family's wishes for her to marry her rapist, Carmela became the third Sicilian
在家庭的支持下，并受到弗兰卡·维奥拉（Franca Viola）此前展现出的勇气和决心的鼓舞，马特奥（Mateo）举报了强奸她的人。她告诉警方，她从未同意与安德烈（Andrea）私奔，也绝不会嫁给他。马特奥立即起诉了安德烈·维蒂奥索（Andrea Viettiosso）。二十四天后，18岁的卡梅拉·帕里西（Carmela Parisi）在西西里岛中部被绑架，并被弗兰科·马图拉（Franco Mattura）强奸。尽管她的家人希望她嫁给强奸犯，但卡梅拉成为了第三位拒绝这一习俗的西西里
girl to refuse the convention. The floodgates had opened. Girls and young women throughout Sicily were now breaking the tradition that had punished them per centuries. It took her further 15 years before the law that rewarded sexual violence with marriage was finally repealed. In 2014, 66-year-old Franca Viola was awarded the honor of Grand Officer of the Order of Merit of the Italian Republic by then-president Giorgio Napolitano.
女孩。闸门已经打开。西西里岛各地的女孩和年轻女性现在都在打破几个世纪以来惩罚她们的传统。又过了15年，这项以婚姻奖励性暴力的法律才最终被废除。2014年，66岁的弗兰卡·维奥拉被时任总统乔治·纳波利塔诺（Giorgio Napolitano）授予意大利共和国功绩勋章大军官勋位。
Franca received the award for her brief but powerful contribution to the emancipation of women in Italy. The following year, Franca agreed to a rare interview with Italian newspaper La Repubblica in which she reflected on her life and experiences. She emphasized the importance of family support and explained the advice she had recently given to her granddaughter. Quote, You have to decide what is right, not what is convenient. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
弗兰卡因其对意大利妇女解放事业短暂而有力的贡献而获得该奖项。次年，弗兰卡接受了意大利《共和国报》（La Repubblica）的一次罕见采访，她在采访中回顾了自己的生活和经历。她强调了家庭支持的重要性，并解释了她最近给孙女的建议。引用如下：“你必须决定什么是正确的，而不是什么是方便的。”本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。